Speaker 1: Hey, David, what happened to defund
the police?
Did they do it?
And why isn't anyone talking about it anymore?
Yeah, I don't know if the question is being
asked cynically or sarcastically or rhetorically.
So a bunch of different things happen.
First of all, society has just sort of moved
on in some sense.
And I don't mean altogether from defund the
police.
There's still a ton of activism going on,
but it's not the lead story on CNN, MSNBC
and FOX every single day.
It's not making headlines in the world's most
read, the country's most read newspaper.
So in a sense, the topic of defund the police
is simmer down.
Now, you all know I was never for defund the
police.
I was for how would I say it?
I was for fund more crime prevention and better
trained police by providing the appropriate
resources for the policing situation as judged
on an individual basis.
That's a terrible tagline.
I'm not a marketing guy, I admit that.
But for me, the idea of eliminating or defunding
police never made sense.
I laid out all the reasons why and and absent
some real way to prevent crime, defunding
police I just don't think is something that
that was ever going to really catch on.
Now, what I do think is typically police are
responding to crime.
So, sure, investigative units, joint terrorism
task force, FBI, CIA, you know, you've got
all these different entities and many of them
are working on preventing major crimes from
happening in advance.
Police mostly are responding to crimes and
are not nearly as often in a situation where
they can prevent one.
Sometimes police interfere or interject into
a situation where a crime has been committed
and they prevent further crime.
So in a shooting where two people have been
killed, police show up, maybe nobody else
gets killed, which could happen if the shooter
is just left alone.
But for the most part, police are not really
day to day street.
Police are not preventing crime in the way
that maybe we would like to see happen.
Access to social workers and mental health
services prevents crime, food stamps and anything
that makes people to be in a less desperate
situation where there might they might feel
compelled to commit a crime to feed their
family or themselves that prevents crime,
good schools, prevent crime, prevent crime,
good public transit, so people can get to
where the jobs are that prevents crime, affordable
sports.
And, you know, the way that we prevent crime
has less to do with police themselves, with
all of the exceptions that I listed.
So I think that the focus should really be,
let's fund crime prevention and reform the
police with the 10 to 12 bullet point outline
that I've given in the past in terms of just
the dialog around defund.
There are cities that recently have been seeing
more violence, not because they defunded.
Now, this is really important.
You see some Republicans, Don Junior, will
do this.
He'll say look at what defund the police brought
to this city.
And then you look and it's like, yeah, they
had to defund the police protest, but the
police weren't defunded.
You can't blame defunding the police for crime
when the police were not defunded.
I do think that more visible crime in some
cities over the last six months has probably
a little bit taken the wind out of the sails
of the straight up defund movement.
It should do nothing at all to take our minds
off of the fund.
Crime prevention and reform of the police
movement.
That's where I've been for years on this issue.
And I see more of my audience coming around
to it.
And I think that that's a very good thing.
Let me know what you think.
And we have a fantastic bonus show planned
for you today.
Join Pakman Dotcom and sign up to get instant
access to today's bonus show.
Unidentified: We will
see
you then.